mr bean is an absolute cult classic
whether you're talking about the movie
the sitcom
even the animation series well today i'm
going to be taking a look at all of them
so we can have a laugh
and learn something in the process are
you ready bee whoop or should i say
sir it's urgent we have a ruptured
kidney and massive bleeding
okay stethoscope down i want to know how
they got a ruptured kidney kidneys
generally just don't self-combust so i
need to know why this kidney ruptured
feeling
[Music]
hello doctor we've got a 45 year old
male 1 type b negative brought in by
paramedics 10 minutes ago he's got a
penetrating injury to the left chest
all right no no no my man needs to scrub
in before he goes to the operating room
there's a very strict way how this
happens first you put on your surgeon's
cap you put on your mask then you start
washing your hands and you do a very
thorough scrub process where you
disinfect
and make sure you're sterile up until
your elbows once you're sterile you walk
into the room making sure you're not
making contact with anything
they then have the sterile gown for you
which you insert your hands through
quite gently then they have their
sterile gloves and all this is a process
that must be followed to a tee to make
sure that you don't cross contaminate
the sterile environment so no they don't
just dress you and you run into the
operating room like all right i'm going
to save the world now i know where that
meme comes from number one number two
you don't touch your mask when you're in
the or that's not part of the sterile
field
if you touch it you then have to
disinfect throw everything off and
restart the whole process again
not sterile m ms what is it
what was that i think it's a bullet oh
oh don't eat it
oh no because that is an m m an m m is
made of chocolate and the body is
warm when it fell into the body cavity
it would automatically melt a little bit
of the sugar off and that sugar would
then remain in the body and serve as a
breeding ground for bacteria
and sepsis for the patient once they
close them up so that is actually a
really really big problem you should be
irrigating that with some saline water
stat it's crashing on us what's his
pulse 38 that's no bueno that means he's
crashing his heart rate is dropping the
suture car behind mr b there is quite
accurate we do have a lot of different
types of sutures for varying utilities
depending on what kind of procedure
you're doing
[Music]
sorry we're we're losing him i've got to
get in there now
[Music]
well doctor you can't just it's too
dangerous
oh
[Music]
by removing the bullet you did not save
the patient's life
imagine someone got shot it tore a hole
in their arteries and their organs
and by taking out that bullet you have
not solved the problem of the fact that
the patient is bleeding internally so no
mr bean didn't just save him by going
any kind of damage to the brain is a
very sensitive thing
to observe so maybe we should just step
outside and give the doctor a little
room to work
the first nurse said we shouldn't think
of this a coma but more like a deep
sleep
yes that's sort of true jennifer
he talks wakey breakfast ready
jennifer
still in his bloody scrubs
defibrillators are not there for you to
play with or to wake
patients up they're meant literally to
restart your heart and when i say
restart it doesn't mean that if your
heart is flat lining
these help it restart what it does is it
actually stops the heart
and allows it to restart on its own so
it's almost like
interrupting the natural rhythm of the
heart the reason we do the
defibrillation
is in certain instances if a patient has
an irregular rhythm to the point where
it's a useless rhythm
or it's going too fast we can then
control it by doing one of these very
controlled shocks depending on the
rhythm that we see on the monitor and mr
bean
do not use the defibrillator to wake
people up
he didn't say clear
[Music]
what is up with that doctor's feet is he
a genie and i don't know what that is in
the foot of his bed if that's his ekg my
man's having a heart attack and we need
to call we need to call somebody we need
to call a cardiologist cause that's not
normal
no then let's take your temperature
he's going to give himself a fever right
be ready this is malingering at its
finest where he's trying to pretend he's
ill in order to get care from somebody
else there's actually
individuals where there's munchausen
syndrome by proxy
when you have an individual who is
keeping their family members sick so
they're reliant on them i'm gonna link
some
resources down below just because i
think it's a really interesting read
oh oh yeah i don't understand she
checked his temperature he had a fever
she's rushing him to x-ray
does she want to check if he has a
pneumonia maybe you want to listen to
his lungs first
[Music]
oh no is he gonna get an x-ray of his
chest that they're gonna see
teddy bear first of all a teddy bear
wouldn't show up like that
unless the teddy bear was made out of
like metal but otherwise you wouldn't
just see an outline with the bear
how about putting him to sleep get a
little anesthesiology action in there
no we don't sharpen our scalpels like
we're going cooking
[Music]
look at the signs in the background here
poorly to the right
healthy to the left cured to the right
restaurant to the right
what is a poorly come back here
again signs restaurant chapel bar
exit down debt first of all what
hospital has a bar
actually i think a grey's anatomy
hospital might have a bar i remember
them like in the first episode
right in between of doing a procedure
and being post call they were like let's
just go grab a drink at the bar and then
they all come back to the hospital like
10 minutes later where is that bar
maybe it's in the hospital
[Applause]
[Music]
there's gonna be some serious burns on
his hand
there's definitely an icd-10 code the
icd-10 is the international
classification of diseases manual 10
and it's gotten so specific that if i
have a patient come in as a result of a
fall
i can't just type in fall i mean i can
but it's going to give me
all these sub definitions like fall on
concrete fall on curb fall in park
fallen gym
fall on grass recently mowed i'm not
even joking i'm gonna try and find some
weird ones to pop up on screen here
[Music]
there's a good reason why all ambulances
have a giant sign on the back of them
that say
keep at least 50 yards back so they
could actually
open their back door and allow the
patient or help the patient
escort the patient into the hospital
because a lot of times they're
uh on a mobile bed in order for that bed
to come out you can't have a car parked
directly behind it
[Music]
what is in it why is he have a tea
kettle
oh no don't take her ticket
that's so evil
[Applause]
oh that's worse than licking the
hospital floor
the dirtiest part of your body are your
fingers and everyone's touching that
thing and you know
here's another 90s funny sitcom me
reviewing medical scenes from seinfeld
and
here's the truth about cracking your
knuckles so i just did it but click here
to find out what that truth is and as
always stay happy and healthy
[Music]